i'm eating peanuts or something
and they get caught in my throat and i'm
bad
and it came out and i bought it but i
was already dozing off so i went out
boom and hit the floor
and i was saying i was in the house by
myself and if that thing was that i
would have died and nobody wanted to
know wasn't that [ __ ] i'm a creepy thing
yeah out of all the things
yeah it's crazy
[Music]
what a trip
[Music]
welcome back to hot boxing i'm mike
tyson and right here is my friend
danielle
mark and chad and we're entrepreneurs
and we want to make up the world a
better place isn't that correct yeah a
little bit right absolutely
that's the mission so that's what we're
doing guys
so tell me how do you feel about this
daniel
how about our work together yes yeah and
i mean it's uh
oh
uh i mean for you
as a person as a brand um it's inspiring
for me to just continually
see you speak your truth
and that really resonates with me and
alternative treatments
um you know
classic medicines from nature is
something that i'm very passionate about
um i've gotten into trouble with you
know opiates in the past uh in my past
career after surgeries and things like
that and cannabis and psychedelics
really
helped me
um
really grab a hold of my life and and
shift perspective of the world and and
the way that i can recover and
communicate with other people and
strengthen my relationships and feel
more connected so
i'm i'm all for you know marijuana i'm
all for psychedelics and what you're
doing at tyson ranch i think is is
nothing short of of amazing in the way
that you advocate for these different
medicines is uh
i woke up boom straight
never had the desire to drink i just
wanted to be um the best of my height to
the height of my possibilities right
right i mean um five mu has been a part
of my journey you know big dose
psilocybin uh really helped me recover
uh my quality of life my brain
i'm gonna do it yeah today
that's great that's great with a shaman
with somebody uh you know proper dosage
set setting yeah yeah
i go up to like a
250. okay
okay when do you know that you that you
need it like do you get called to it or
or do you yeah
yeah
because when i did it it was um it was a
stack therapy like a full day
and i was i was really there to to save
my life i was in a similar position that
you were right with everything kind of
um my relationships were i was i was
depressed i was suicidal and um and
these these medicines really helped
bring me out of it um and then you you
dive into the science about it how they
they connect different hemispheres of
the brain that were once shut down
i mean um
you know it's it's it's pretty
remarkable this is pretty remarkable
daniel why is it when i do mushrooms or
something
um the [ __ ] trees and plants start
talking me and they're moving and [ __ ]
that happened to you too
yeah i i high at high dose yeah for sure
there's hallucinations
but that's the key is is is like uh
tolerance and then and then you build up
the more that you take this medicine if
you don't take a break
you you really don't want to tolerance
start off slow yeah yeah when you go
back to it yeah yeah he's being like my
stuff slow slow enough so let's try this
28 back to your five yeah right cheese
geez i like to think i like to think
yeah i don't know if i find my way back
to successful
um
yeah yeah yeah man
i mean it does
like what i'm interested in too is you
know a lot of people are doing high dose
to for depression or or for anxiety or
or to come back i think i think i think
what's that
what's that docent again they do i
forgot um
like a micro dose micro no [ __ ] yeah
yeah yeah they do that microdose that
that meddles a lot of guys out for sure
on a daily basis yeah right and then too
much might get you weird but that's a
little michael to keep you level uh-huh
for sure i mean it hits it hits all the
right um happy chemicals in the brain
right serotonin
yeah yeah and over a longer period of
time like it does show and it keeps you
sharp real sharp
but like that's what i'm interested in
amplified performance yeah it amplifies
it and i think it's crazy about what
we've learned
it can amplify your it's like
when you're
daniel always says about it sharpens
certain aspects that you're already
sharp and it makes you even multiplies
it right
which could be
good or bad yeah
depending on the person and depending on
the strain the genetics of the strain
depending on why you're using it that's
the biggest that's the biggest thing is
is intention i always have an intention
anytime that i micro dose or any time
that i go into a ceremony it's for a
very specific reason um and then when i
come out or during that ceremony i
always get what i need because
psilocybin specifically exasperates or
or what's at the forefront of our mind
right so it's so funny you said that
everything that i um
i forgot i forgot what they call
manifest
came true mm-hmm right and it's so weird
and i mean it just came true right i
think though back to the stories like
tyson ranch has so much potential right
you know where it's where it's going and
your brand like people want to recap i
love that word recap oh it's a beautiful
word recap the thing is about what you
guys are doing also like from an
education standpoint growing up i think
everyone growing up were told drugs
drugs which was just one big name not a
specific drug just leave from that way
i'm from new york right yeah um
but wherever you're from just drugs were
anti-productivity yeah
if you were an athlete forget it it
would be the opposite thing that you
would ever consider doing whether it was
cigarettes alcohol weed or anything
harder lazy stoners right yeah ladies
and gentlemen i'll be honest before i
started in cannabis that was my you know
thought yeah you have to get educated
yeah i wasn't educated so you have work
to do clearly meaning the fact that you
guys are proponents for education and
the added value benefits that aren't
about just partying getting [ __ ] up
and then like passing out throwing yeah
so enticing ranch you're gonna
eventually go out well to put a
university up there cannabis university
and educate the people how they just
grow how you make screen you know it's
gonna be really fun
educational perspective well you have
the opportunity now that legality is on
your side also right like when like an
fda approves something it becomes okay
to take even
not only that and tyson ranch will be
able to not only sell
um cannabis the first time it had me be
able to sell liquor which i think is
yucky but i guess this is the business
that i'm in yeah and um
this will be the first time i think that
happened
yeah it's yeah i mean we for the company
that i have a few all we do is work with
cannabis to basically make sure they're
following legalities so it's just in it
just getting bran i mean in the world of
cannabis brands struggle the same way
like you know a craft or even a catch
you can market to anybody you want to
come to your restaurant in cannabis yeah
right so you had it well now you can i
mean you have to work through it but
that was when we jumped in just to
really figure out how to make that you
know have the same playing field but the
regulations are allowing for a new
conversation it's really like the
benefits double-edged sword like you're
regulated but as a result of being legal
with regulation you're now allowed to
talk to people about things other than
it's good for you why well they'll
believe it if it's legal if it's still
illegal it's like don't talk to me about
it because
it's illegal right like alcohol is
probably the worst thing you can do to
your body and yeah that's been illegal
and everybody drinks it and everyone
celebrates with it and it's okay and the
stigma
i went to the same bars with some
friends soon as i went there the
government came in and gave me license
for now for cannabis for the cat for the
caribbean
as soon as one day the guy came out they
were going to come check me pat me down
or something
they handed me the to carry it not sell
it but like to have it just
yeah you know okay this is the ticket to
sell cannabis yeah yeah
as well yeah to the caribbean
[Music]
i want to pause to talk about a product
that's great for anyone active as an
athlete i sweat and i sweat a lot and
when i do i lose electrolytes and if i'm
not hydrated losing electrolytes like
sodium can give me a headache or make me
tired instead of energizing me even if
you're not an athlete things like this
can happen if you're fast or if you do
low-carb diets you can feel like [ __ ]
and some people even get muscle cramps
everyone needs electrolytes that's why
their element there's no sugar no
coloring no artificial nothing that's
why i love it it's no [ __ ] dozens of
players in nfl nba and nhl are already
on a monthly element subscription if you
want to try go to drinkelement.com
hotboxing to get your free sample pack
now
[Music]
and it's also used by badass navy seals
fbi snipers and marines and mike tyson
the baddest [ __ ] on the planet
[Music]
i mean the war on drugs is just
absolute failure and when you think
about schedule one
drugs marijuana
so and then psilocybin magic mushrooms
right uh high abuse liability which we
know isn't true
and no medicinal value there are medical
marijuana programs all over the united
states but this they are still both
federally
illegal right just because of the
scheduling if we can continue to educate
and we can continue to push forward
awareness on what these medicines can do
the descheduling the reason i'm very
passionate about decrem movements
is to get these medicines de-scheduled
so then you can bring them into the
context of making them a medicine
without the red tape so it won't take me
five to seven years with we sauna to
research the active ingredient of
psilocybin
for
depression or or traumatic brain injury
related anxiety so i mean we have a
you know what you're doing with your
following and your platform and tyson
ranch is is is extremely important and
what you're doing for psychedelics as
well and i'm just grateful that you know
i don't know how we met we were talking
about this the other day you were
sitting here we were you and i'm just
you're sitting about we were sitting in
my office when colbot happened and we
worked out of my we worked out of my
office called the war room a lot of good
things happened there yeah um and i was
like you know we need to help the stigma
type we were thinking about we just i
have philo we were starting wesana he
came he reached out to me on linkedin
and uh
and i'm like we got to get mike on
working with us because mike has a great
footprint on talking with mushrooms then
we had brian spears
working at filo reached out to the zine
got us in
touch with mike and that's how we're
here
it's all crazy how cannabis psilocybin
they all are intertwined you see all the
same people involved because
very similar missions like you said
right at the same time you're fighting
the same battle right and it's
destigmatizing something that i learned
that like athletes like you guys you
know you gotta you're at a sporting
event you're watching daniel carson
fight or mike fight it heavyweight no
one knows about the damage that you guys
deal with after
i think what's what we hope to see too
is
athletic organizations right allowing
people to utilize same thing treatments
you guys have so i think the government
is so afraid of this medicine
you know but marijuana sales are
smashing alcohol sales in illinois like
once they start what talks right is tax
money money yeah right so like that's
why you're seeing the
acceptance right i think you saw that co
i mean i you saw with covid
our business blew up when it became an
essential right right i can't go to
catch
and get some sushi with my friends but i
can go to the retail dispensary and buy
weed right so it change it changed uh it
changed the game yeah mark for your
question for you though with eventually
where it goes with like lounges you know
canvas lounges eventually will come out
more and more like would you think
anything would ever happen with you with
what you're doing would you ever have
lounges in the restaurant or in the back
we have our own little lounge as well
yeah no but um
when it becomes a actual cannabis lounge
with food and beverage i don't know that
i would do
catch with that yeah but you know like
being in the culinary business um and we
come and talk to your team about that
idea in general like what would really
go well with it like is it sushi or is
it like the greatest italian you know
pizza and
and like easy food to have that you
would desire maybe but just like a
dumbed-down version of like a
sophisticated restaurant well it's like
wine when you look at canvas like wine
you can correlate uh strains with food
yeah but you would have to really do a
pairing it would just be like throw
catch on it no no no no in general you
know but i think that look food and
beverage goes with everything every
activity we do revolves around that so
certainly
you know as things get more creative and
and and
entrepreneurs start entering those
markets because of legality you will see
probably a tremendous amount of pairing
and yeah high middle and low you know
consumer you know pricing or whatever
it's going to be yeah it's going to be
it's going to be interesting in the next
two years you know if you're wearing
tyson ranch we had ideas to make a
little you know town there pretty much
and um i was always wanting to um
because i was gonna be a guest at the
carnaval in rio yeah i would say on
something nice because there's a
thousand acres up there we could it
would be like cuba back in the 50s and
40s show girls
movies just labyrinth um
luxury houses and stuff
and i and i
think that was going to be a winner
mm-hmm and you look right off he was
right
um
i'm looking at the freeway right here so
easy to get here he's come up nice
and it's closer than
cello coach elliott yeah yeah
there's you're at really like this
pinnacle moment in time in an industry
like you can call it you know the way
prohibition ended and
the amount of innovation that came out
of that revolving around legal alcohol
selling you're in the same kind of
kind of moment now where
even the conversation the fact that
you're having conversations at regular
dinner tables all across the country
about marijuana being legal and then
getting into businesses and you've got
young entrepreneurs all over the place
which stimulates no different than tech
amazing amounts of ideas and creativity
and
it's like the type of amusement park
space around who knows but i'm saying
there's really no end you're at the very
beginning of it you're at the forefront
of like this huge industry that we
already know has a giant demand well
it's interesting when we were when we
were filo technology company we came
from mainstream i tried to hire people
people like they'd be interviewing for
the job they'd be like oh is this good
for my resume i'm like you're not right
fit for this yeah we started to bring in
you know feel top talent from all that
like you said from the mainstream world
and people just want a new challenge
yeah and it's it's again it's it's like
fun to learn something and educate
yourself right and so and be at the
forefront of like influence how people
actually like smoke and how people are
going to you know take these everything
i don't even like calling them drugs but
like take these medicines you know yes
uh it's pretty in olympics in 1924
the bike riders
throw the bikes they was passing
cigarettes to one another
and they were right oh yeah right before
they thought it was bad for them doctors
were smoking in commercials talking
about how healthy it is it's it's you
know it's an exciting time for a lot of
different things but especially in the
in the cannabis and controlled substance
space i think it's going to be
you know you've got pop culture getting
involved you've got television shows
creating shows whether it's like this is
the beginning stage of the anti-aging
program yes yeah but it takes a little
longer yeah what's your opinion on nad
you know what that is nad
yeah i tried doing that with uh
when i got covet it's i don't know they
say it manipulates
reverse the aging of your cells
they say mushrooms does that too
you look younger what doesn't mushrooms
do that's that's the day
five years he said from
from a picture when you came out of nhl
to where you are today you look yeah the
before and afters so one thing that you
see after big dose i don't know if you
notice it but um uh
you look
younger because of the potent
anti-inflammatory anti-oxidant benefits
of mushrooms post-hallucination post
okay yeah post-serum not seeing yourself
no no no the first day
not so good second day third day
um
what mushrooms do for like the gi tract
in your stomach because 90 of our
serotonin receptors aren't up here 90 of
them are in the gut that's why they say
the gut brain axis is so important uh
and such a strong connection so when you
think of it that way and and you
understand psilocybin and what how it
like it is a lock and key for serotonin
and that's why
sometimes you like get a little
of the energy stomach
cranks you here yeah yeah yeah craziest
feeling ever but i mean this is natural
so like it's very different than nad
this is from
spiritual photography right now correct
yeah and we can you can get really
spiritual about it but these mushrooms
have been around
for millions and millions and millions
of years it's called a technology
because native americans have used it
for
so if you
use it like very intentionally
um you can get these amazing benefits i
don't like
anti-aging maybe but it's just it makes
people have sat with over 80 people now
the last two and a half years and and
led people through it it just makes you
um
look younger
uh i think it's because of the way that
it makes you feel um
and we hold our
stress points right in our in our face
the fda has well validated endpoints for
how we hold stress in our face maybe
there's a mushroom cream in your future
maybe that
there's gonna be some like there's maybe
something coming down in the future yeah
there's there's definitely something
coming in the future speak to me you
seem very smart you're almost like a
scientist help me out who are we
who are we yeah oh man
[Music]
i don't know how long do we got yeah all
day
you know yeah i mean while we just
talking with my great my
father and men it's just a compound
needs and necessities they never can be
satisfied
and even then when when they are
satisfied it's a it's a feeling of
feeling this and abandonment you know
so
what is success who are we
how come how come how can we get 20 40
billion or something and we kill
ourselves
i think i think success is not measured
by money no that's not measured by even
stature what is success
i was big time stars about saying that
yeah what's what is it that this does
depends to people i don't know like in
in my journey i think success is just
like really understanding who i am
what works for me what doesn't um
because then if i know and i i start
loving myself and i start like caring
for myself then others around me will
see it it's contagious the energy that's
what i believe as well you know and then
um
that's you know we can get really deep
into a rabbit hole but there's a
spiritual aspect to the medicine
uh and and it's completely changed my
life the last two and a half years my
perspective not only on myself but of
the world right i i
i don't stress about the same things
anymore i don't worry about
um you know slitting throats anymore
like it's i don't fight anymore and for
my whole life i grew up in canada yeah
oh listen listen fought everybody you
know i was a fighting [ __ ] talking
[ __ ]
oh listen you shouldn't met me i'm glad
you didn't meet me and i was in your
place back then i saw somebody in line
or my ex-wife or something oh i was just
a madman yeah i'm sorry i missed that to
be
honest and i just told you and you said
love everything's about love man yeah
well that kind of behavior or that kind
of reaction which is what we're talking
about like really reactive
behavior is unsustainable right it only
has an ending which is basically in
trouble of some sort whether you're
getting arrested
divorced sued all that [ __ ] comes with
reactivity right right big fan and i
feel like
if you're truly you know a lot of people
that are like that in my
vast
experience of meeting a lot of people
because in the nightclub business since
i'm
19 basically and now i'm 44
and in nightclubs you see it all because
you add personality and mix it with
alcohol it's like a celery like a club
catch is a fun restaurant but in new
york we had many nightclubs where i
started out i didn't start in
restaurants i started nightclubs my
first one was 24 years old and
and it was a success it was a success
to me
you know it it's a building block to
where i am sitting right now this is
like
a moment of success for me because i've
idolized you watched you since i'm a
child as many people tell you thank you
and to be sitting with you even having a
conversation or having you in my
restaurant
is a
gift and a success and i think i've made
it you know what i mean like there's
these moments and there's not a lot of
them by the way you're one of those
moments to me well you've got a great
restaurant so thank you very much thank
you thank you for catching us
in new york
aspen coming soon
we might we really mad through a good
meet your friend but i've been a catch i
was telling him i was going to catch i
telling my friends yeah yeah but uh you
know i agree with what he said though
like i used to watch your fights with my
grandpa and they're on now pass but i
used to watch every we all get together
to watch mike tyson fight and you know
so like city you know it isn't nostalgic
that's why i tell you like tyson ranch
your brand it means something in the
canvas space because like daniel in the
mushroom space you are
you push this with no fear the same i
always tell him when he we're you know
working together it sounds like champion
mindsets and you have one anyone that's
successful
and you know both at home and at work
you have to have a mindset that you're
you know resilient but if you're not
fair if you have no fear then you're
saying you're crazy man i don't think so
you can't help anybody fear is your
friend yeah fear helps you excel
makes you hot punch harder fear is your
weapon i always try to tell my daughter
that
that book is not a book it's a weapon
you know they don't get it yet yeah
and but that's the thing about you
specifically you like there isn't not
everyone can go out and create a brand
after retirement after
the life that you've led to
and succeed because you were so unique
so special and so significant to so many
people at so many different ages
you transcend from like i'm talking like
i could i might have been nine or ten my
brother is obsessed with you and he was
three years younger than me my dad was
obsessed with you and he's 20 years old
and still to this day everyone that
walks basically the earth as far as i'm
concerned in modern day that has had a
television or you know
knows who you are and as a result
they have a passion to understand where
are you today and what is your mindset
and they will follow it i think because
you were so s special in the sport that
you
excelled in beyond anyone's really
dreams or expectations of what you can
do in a sport
and now in business to do the same
i'm just unbelievable it's authentic you
know i'm just um i'm a strong exponent
of gratitude
with the universe giving me gratitude i
don't take that for granted yeah and
you're vulnerable too you know i think
that's what draws a lot of people to you
right is that authentic
vulnerability
well you're honest there's all the glory
whatever it is
it goes to god you know i mean you don't
want to hear that i'm just a human being
i want to be able to walk the streets or
people you know i mean ramsacking me i
i'm trying my best not to be that guy
that wants to hide and get away from the
people i want to be able to i'm just
here you know because i'm not going to
allow myself my fame to imprison me i'm
just not going to do that yeah
[Music]
well to be happy what i was saying is
you know you see people
being reactive like
saying before like in the nightclub side
you take someone who's a whatever
however they behave in normal life then
you add alcohol to it and then you see
really what they're about
and
most people that are reactive are just
not happy or they're insecure or they're
not they haven't found really themselves
to be comfortable in their own skin
no no and then i know some people that
um
blame it on alcohol and get off
yeah yeah i was alcohol did this to me
and those guys were giving me that
alcohol yeah you know everyone doesn't
um
it's not
everybody doesn't have one of those
upbeat
finishes in life yeah yeah i mean but
don't you think that alcohol sometimes
triggers like who someone really is kind
of trying to they try to maintain
themselves but then with the alcohol
they
can't alcohol kill more people than all
the drugs in the world combined is that
something that's crazy unbelievable in
all ages
um car accidents
become alcoholic really bad and then
when you stop drinking you're really sad
i have no personality right you know
it's just crazy yeah i mean it's all
about lubricant yeah it's a proven
neurodegenerative but i mean i think
it's
you know you find a space and it's
manageable just like everything else
right um 19 drinks after 19 drinks it
becomes a little yeah
dicey but one or two drinks and the
problem is most people can't yeah yeah
it would be nice if everyone's family
sometimes i'll be honest i tell my wife
sometimes how come [ __ ] up evil people
never get addicted
huh what's wrong with that how come they
don't get drunk how come they don't get
drunk they don't get high they don't use
cocaine
because they probably get off [ __ ]
people
that's right because sociopaths that is
their drug yeah criminals they have
different drugs you know drugs addiction
is
different yeah it doesn't have to be
germany
either you can destroy somebody's
companies worth around 40 million
dollars or 200 billion dollars
for no reason
that's the biggest that's the biggest
learning experience you have i think any
business owner entrepreneur you just
don't know people are like that you walk
into narcissists and they have no they
don't give a [ __ ] and they do get a lot
of them get away with that i mean like i
don't know
when you're
fighting like when i was in my career i
mean man sometimes that mentality of
knowing that i had to
kill anybody that was in front of me
helped me survive so i think it's again
it just always goes back to but you
still have fear right yeah
oh yeah man
healthy healthy fear for sure uh you
always if you're not
here it's something yeah exactly um only
healthy when you know how to control it
yeah if you don't control it it's going
whack it's like a fire if you control
fire you can make it heat and cook foods
for us and if you let it go out of
control kills everything around you
yeah yeah i mean you just again like
mike said you just use it you hone you
hone it if you let it take over you
you're gonna be
uh you know you're not gonna be on the
attack but if you use it um
to your advantage you can really
be comfortable in that space so there's
a saying in in hockey like i was very
comfortable being uncomfortable for a
long time you know because not only like
when that when training camp starts you
are immediately breaking down your body
you usually get two to three
months to rebuild it but it's it's a
tough way to live and it's a tough
lifestyle but um you know talking about
like being reactive and how to use fear
man my first
you know seven years of pro i was uh
always drinking i was always using like
numbing agents like opiates and pain
killers
you know it's uh it was dark like i
didn't have any success those first five
years other than
i was killing guys like
in these fights you know and i was i was
surviving but i wasn't i definitely
wasn't uh my healthiest version and then
you know
um last five years kind of
i i i had to ask for help because you
could see all these signs that it's
starting to like fall apart yeah the
family says hey
yeah you got no close relationships
you're like you know you're isolated
by yourself your friends don't like you
know starting to get you know no teams
want to sign you yeah you help me hear
that kid help me get out yeah
you can do that you know it was the best
thing that i ever did when i asked for
help because then i got introduced to
like meditation uh you know marijuana
like all of these i'm just addicted to
rehab yeah and every time i get into a
go up there i can get a girlfriend and
hang out with the movies just like
the babysitter in us right yeah yeah
camp for adults yeah but behavior camp
right
yeah
yeah but no like i mean i changed
everything my last five years i went to
the stanley cup finals
three times four with um
with four different teams and uh
it was uh it was different like when i
came back from rehab i couldn't fight
the same way like i couldn't think the
same way i was much more kind of like
on my heels yeah and that is not good
like you have to be for me and for any
hockey player reactionary you cannot
think on the ice because there's so many
things happening and moving um
and so once you start thinking which i
was because now all of a sudden i was
more connected to myself i was more i
understood what i was doing other people
what was probably happening to me um and
uh
it changed i couldn't change it
everywhere this is [ __ ] crazy
i'm gonna blow your mind
and it blows my mind
a second in hockey is very slow
you have to have 10 three tenths of a
second it's a [ __ ]
it's nothing
you know what i mean a minute i mean
a second just give me a second there's
nothing in sports like hockey it's
nothing yeah yeah you get hit in the
second you out flat yeah and that's the
second yeah
before the show was second yeah
yeah
yeah yeah yeah you got 10 10 guys moving
at a average speed of 30 miles an hour
there's no out of bounds uh you're
managing a puck you're moving to open
space you're never passing to a person
you're passing ahead of them all the
while you're on ice making you're on ice
yeah you're on you know a quarter inch
of steel and then um you're making sure
that you don't get your head taken off
you know um and you're trying to put
that yeah
do you have all your teeth no no oh no
all three of these upside down
i used to have it but i kept like them
when you eat you take it out and i kept
putting in napkins and then like waiters
or waitresses would come by us and just
scoop it up because it looked like
garbage i lost somebody right yeah like
mike's like get the new they're sharp
yeah they're sharp get the new teeth oh
i got them i got posts yeah that's crazy
but i think even why is this why is the
teeth
because sticks right you stick some
pucks and you just wear a mouth guard
and your face is exposed um some guys
wear visors but your your whole face is
so you know when like a wide receiver
jumps up to a pass that's too high over
the middle and he knows he's going to
get crushed in the middle that is what i
feel like hockey is the entire time
yeah you're just going to get buried
into some sort of wall or person or like
puck is going to slam what's been
amazing and i know you're going to see
boxing
hockey
you can really kind of
stand back
so it's the only sport where you can
fight with
bare knuckles right like i can
um there's no protection uh but
that sport was like managing all those
different things you have to have so
much attention to detail um and then you
can transfer
i i don't like a lot of things about
hockey right like the culture um a lot
of things are wrong um and it and it
formed me into a person that i never
want to be again but i can take some of
those like work ethic attributes and
attention detail
coachability and and then turn that into
being an entrepreneur and a ceo and you
know i tell him i've told him before but
he's like one of the best coaches that
i've ever had because i wasn't so sure
that i would be able to make the
transfer from athlete to
um you know ceo of a life sciences
company researching psilocybin for
traumatic brain injury you know i've
been impossible with nothing to people
to try yeah
and yeah and i wanted to listen too you
know like yeah it's been uh it's been a
pretty pretty crazy journey yeah
it's bob you said fear like i should i
agree it's like
honing your fear i remember when
daniel's getting in front of all these
you know at this summit his ceo someone
was all these phds and he's like you
know they're all phds in like the
european what you've done you know more
than most of these people on this panel
gets up crushes it i've never met a guy
that knows more than he does in this
specific area so it's like he's got it
it was nerve that was when you had some
fear yeah but it was like it was a big
win he accelerates me yeah me too makes
me see better here better
everything focus better
it's like that feeling you know in
business it drives me big time yeah the
fear of the fear of
failure actually yeah drives me like i i
always would say like in in the
nightclub days and now the restaurant
days every time we opened a club or
opened a restaurant
even when it was already succeeding i
had the same feeling as i did when i was
like 10 years old and i had a birthday
party and i felt like i wasn't that
popular and i didn't know if anyone's
going to show up
that feeling
i've never lost yeah it get it does not
go away i i still every day like
he walks in another person walks into
the restaurant that's important or not
important
i still need to get up off the couch
whether i've been successful or
unsuccessful same mentality of if i
don't get off the couch and go into that
restaurant or go into my business
to add some sort of value or create some
sort of experience
then someone else is going to and i'm
going to go out of business
it's that simple yeah every little thing
you know like a last night like get a
nice dinner but then
i realized you're there david blaine's
in town i hit him up mike's at the
restaurant where are you i'm cut i'm
coming and then did you have a better
time
or the same time if it was better
then i know that i've added the value
that i'm talking about in that moment
just for rooftop magic man that was that
was a great time
because i had to say this
i didn't have so much fun in so long all
right this is all i want to do everybody
was happy after we just spoke up the
first then we started doing tricks
everybody was happy and laughing oh man
i think this is the business i'm in yeah
yeah
just that atmosphere why come to me you
could spend a hundred dollars anywhere
you know and get like pretty good food
especially in new york city every block
has the rest right after after something
like that who's not going to come back
or recommend yeah if someone texts you
like where should i go i'm coming to l.a
that's what i do i recommend you guys go
to the rooftop catch yeah yeah
in any city and catch also has a you
know i [ __ ] just went vegan like six
months ago and i have every time i go to
catch i always know i can get some good
food think about it you you david was in
there five or ten minutes before he's
hey let me show you something this is my
father absolutely hey let me show you
this take this you can tell you can tell
him
you could go and listen i was over a
hundred pounds i just told i lost 100
pounds in four months
i would love david to do that he's i'm
told what he can do
you know
it'll be his thinking oh yeah it's
already at a a different level yeah i'm
sitting there complaining last night i
was like oh i'm fat i'm intermittent
fasting he looks at me he's like what
are you doing i'm intermittent fasting i
can't eat between
trying to lose you know 10 15 pounds
before the wedding he's like well he
held up the water bottle he goes i
survived on this for 45 days underground
look at how i looked yeah i was like you
know don't complain to me right oh man
yeah you're getting married yeah next
month yeah buddy
congratulations thank you
congratulations 44 finally doing it yeah
yeah why not
how do you think we can make
weed better how can we make better
cannabis how can we intertwine how can
we marry marry it with some psychedelics
how do you think that'll turn out
i think i mean
i think with marinate a second with
cannabis i mean i'm kind of doing that
right now with uh cbd with usana yeah
you're married you're marrying our
compound yeah yeah so what we're
developing that we saw in like a part of
the regiment that helped me get better
is is using a non-psychoactive
cannabinoid so part of the cannabis
plant i want them breed them together
yeah in combination with uh with
psilocybin uh i wonder what that drink's
gonna be like well mike right now tyson
ranch this guy's you know there's no
limits you can figure out how you want
you know let's get involved please i
would love to do that for sure for sure
yeah
you know
ask the uh do some brainstorming with
the toad you know come up with some new
ideas yes i will but yeah nutraceuticals
combining i think the future of medicine
and otc or over-the-counter products are
are combining cannabis with
um uh psychedelics and and functional
mushrooms
right now yeah yeah big one but like you
like that's that's what got me better
man um once i started intermittent
fasting 16-8 is is my
regimen uh my recovery went
like skyrocketed it was it was really
and that's that's the same thing that i
do it's just it's helped my sleep um
it's helped it's helped everything the
the intermittent fasting and and using
these like these natural medicines mike
how many this crazy uh
someone told us yesterday what you said
work out three times a day
excuse me you still work out three times
a day yeah we may go back to it too oh
yeah it's amazing what do you so how do
you do that because i've done once a day
every other day and it was very hard
i do my bike in the morning
my treadmill the afternoon
and then i come back i might just wait
till right through it switch it around
how long when you say do you bike like
an hour 30 minute time first it was 15
minutes because i was 100 pounds every
day 15. 20 20 15 20 and within a couple
of months time i was up to like two
hours oh wow
i was told doing uh uphill walking on a
treadmill is very good
better better for your body everything
yeah burn the calories out yeah same cat
you gotta bring certain same calories
yeah running
yeah it's crazy right you're walking you
don't make this just stupid like i'm not
god made this [ __ ]
find a hill
i have a question off subject how do you
feel about the way sport your sport
boxing is going right now with all the
uh
you know instagram versions of it i know
you love these guys youtube yeah the
youtube fights and the jake paul
suddenly is having heavy weight or
lightweight whatever it is and this is
the deal we took them from a business
perspective
i don't care if it looks goofy or funny
that money's real and these guys are
getting knocked out this is an
entertainment you know listen
i bring the world champion i put him on
my card right
let's say he's a great world champion
right now right uh-huh
i'm giving him some points say um he
gave me he brings a million people
that's a lot i'm giving them up upside
right
this little [ __ ] blonde hair
blue-eyed [ __ ] coming up with 70 million
right yeah so you know i mean it's like
a numbers game purely no no no listen
you have to listen to this [ __ ]
these 70 million people never saw a
boxing match before right yeah and they
coming for this little [ __ ] i love him
yes i play with my card he's beautiful
he's beautiful so from the business
perspective you like it yeah but from
the pure i mean look i look at you and i
think this is a guy who took the sport
and the science and the the the
philosophy of boxing for you didn't do
it for money you did it because you had
the passion then you went to the
olympics and always thing does it
does it cheapen your sport or no that's
all i'm trying to
age upset because changing of the guard
is hard to understand a heart i want to
understand and that's just what it is
it's the changing of the guards and
these um
tick-tock guys are part of it yeah
you understand that all right that's
also getting you it's also getting more
yeah it's getting more exposure listen i
don't know what you're saying just
double that yeah i get it but imagine it
10 years from now
i want to have the
what do you call them again
youtube stars i want to have other
youtube boxers
have a tournament to fight who will be
the champion of the world in that world
and just keep it in that category
but the crossover was so fast that's
what they do they have another belt
it'll be whatever boat they want to be
and then they put that up against the
boxes but it's all hype yeah hype cell
fights fights don't sell fights hype
cell fights yeah but the fact that i
have a conversation with people of
saying like oh it's pre-discussed how
it's gonna go it's gonna be arranged and
all this stuff even though it's a
conversation because i could tell you
when you got in the ring there was no
conversation about whether or not this
guy's gonna take a fall or he's not
gonna hit him in the head everybody's
like them hey how you feeling all right
well i said what about me i was fighting
too yeah i didn't have somebody in the
way
am i all right
that's rep bro yeah your rep precedes
you sorry so listen i'm very happy about
our
collection
and i think it's gonna be really cool
we'll be happy about it nice man it's
gonna be great yeah
i'm excited for you guys yeah it's gonna
be a
fun ride it's been a fun ride
a lot of good things coming on the
horizon you deserve it you know um
amsterdam is not taking no more far on
this
what happened amsterdam's not taking no
more far far it's not selling wheat
amsterdam
yeah farm
what i meant about so if foreign not
from amsterdam you can't buy and then
the people in amsterdam don't smoke yeah
the whole point of them they have the
whole thing they don't get out of the
the the residents right for the tours
the red light district was only for
tourists or whatever they could
do i think they're jealous
silly
well doesn't make sense no foreign
college roommates open up a restaurant
in amsterdam
i brought like chicago deep dish uh his
own little style today yeah yeah
he's doing well you know
i don't oh yeah i don't know
he's a great kid he's doing a podcast
now too will well now yeah he had the
pizza place the deepest yeah
he's got his little puck pizza
i don't know
from a business perspective
what was your greatest moment
you can answer yours first
go down the path um
that moment you says
boom
i'm the best as i'm stealing anybody
[Music]
that's a tough question too yeah it's
tough because i don't even like i don't
really like answering it but uh come on
man keep it real with yourself yeah well
i think um
you know just having a vehicle or having
a business that's gonna that's trying to
do as much as we can to to really
fill in the gaps as far as um traumatic
brain injury and recovery goes and
rehabilitation and then cognitive
performance as well
getting public was
was
you're actually atc he was there yeah
yeah you were on the csc call and um
like meeting you working with you
um you know getting the wbc partnership
as a research partnership was really
exciting recently got some
animal work back that validates that
validates um um you know our our formula
um with uh psilocybin cbd no
drug drug interaction so that now means
that we can put it into human beings um
that was that was big but yeah all of it
i don't like picking one
it's not done yet right there's so much
more to do
i wanted to be a big shot in this
business i just wanted to spin this was
so cool yeah it is cool do you have a
one moment in your boxing career that
was your biggest accomplishment or like
is it one specific fight larry holmes
yeah
because i was a little boy 14 i went
with my mentor and we went to fight him
we would um watch him fight ali ali came
out of retirement and he really beat
ailee up a little bit i was crying and
stuff yeah and that's it that's when it
stands out yes i'm gonna avenge you hmm
for muhammad ali yeah i like that
for me i feel like um i get also stages
but like my first
night club that i
owned and i had my first business
partner that we're still partners today
and we own we owned a club called 10
june
in new york city and uh it's named after
our birthday because my partner and i
are both born on june 10th so we called
it 10 june so we didn't want to call it
mark and eugene so i was like
but we want people to believe us that it
was ours we're like yeah it's our
birthday
yeah and uh
jim and i right yeah geminis and uh
and like i got married that birth june
10th did you
yeah
congratulations because that's a hell of
a day it's on my leg it's in my arm
um
happy anniversary and happy birthday to
me did your first hat too
no my first tattoo was 10 june which is
here six and then the 10 on the other
side and then i just birthdays were
always you know something for me because
of that like it was like my partner and
i met because we had the same birthday
someone introduced us
people were leaving my birthday to go to
his birthday who the [ __ ] is this eugene
guy that people keep losing leaving my
party and going to his party so we
eventually met and we hit it off and we
were the same
kind of like point of view on what we
want to do in the nightlife business do
you ever think um
this is creepy
um let's ask some people this question
yeah
you ever think um
all right i'm gonna i'm not even gonna
go long
yeah i will let's say
10 10 000 years right
the first man if your fam ten thousand
years even your it goes millions a year
but this is ten thousand years
of your man generation come whatever it
is boom
how does that um
how does that make you feel where do you
think ever like this
with my my
1200s grandfather mongolian or something
african or something and then it came
out to me all that led to me
yeah i mean whatever got me to wherever
i'm sitting and how it all
came from where it came from ten
thousand years ago or a million years
ago
it's hard to imagine but i do think that
like the summed up version of it is
you know people say you got lucky and
i'm like well i always think like hard
work meets opportunity
no luck it's just the harder you work
and less
yeah
yeah so it's when your hard work meets
an opportunity and then everyone's like
oh how lucky were you i was like lucky i
have been [ __ ] grinding it for the
last 10 years
and you have to be prepared or suffering
you don't see them private you suffer
the glow in the light yeah i think and
and it's happened a lot and i have it
tattooed right here perspective which to
me is almost like my religion i was
living across the street from the world
trade center when that happened my
friend died of cancer all these things
happened at a young age and i and i
thought to myself
how do i get
upset about essentially anything anymore
when
people had to deal with that or my
friend died at a young age
who i envied very much but i walked out
of his hospital room when he had just
found out that he had cancer this was a
kid that i
was jealous of my whole life growing up
and we were only 20 when he got
diagnosed for 21
and he had a nice watch he had a nice
car and he had fancy clothes and rich
parents and all this kind of stuff and i
always was like man i wish i had i wish
i had i wish i had then this happens
and i leave that room and the only thing
i thought to myself is i just left him
in a hospital gown in the hospital bed
scared to death because he found out he
had a tumor the size of a grapefruit in
his lung
and he would have traded
anything
to get out of that bed and walk out with
me with nothing right
and i'm sitting here like
there's no point of being jealous
envious or wishing you had something
else i was like perspective that's it i
just you know not that you could walk
around the earth and be like well i
don't have cancer so who cares
but it's like
your your lows i find with perspective
aren't as low and your highs aren't as
high with perspective because it's not
always going to be great and it's not
always going to be terrible
and there's always something worse going
on and you have to maintain like you
only have this moment and you're talking
about 10 000 years ago i'm thinking
i'm here you're here we're all here for
a blink of an of a moment in the grand
scheme of a timeline and we live to be
800 years ago
it's still a blink it's like it's hockey
so like how serious can we all take this
[ __ ] the fact that there's war at the
end of the day or the fact that we're
all fighting about even just over money
or trying to get ahead of other people
just i'm sitting here thinking if i'm
healthy and my family is healthy i've
made it and then everything else is sort
of fun how can i have more fun and time
with the people that i like love or what
keeps me interested or busy doing things
that i enjoy period
so the nightclub business i started
after september 11th happened i quit my
job in finance because i hated it but i
was making money doing it but i didn't
like it
that happened that happened i was like
from today forward i will do what i love
and that's it without compromise
money came
success came that helps life get easier
but if you're walking around rich and
miserable every day and i and i've
spoken to many kids or other people who
say like tell me what you know when you
educate in some way when you give back
i'm like if you believe tgif is a thing
like thank god it's friday it's [ __ ]
it sucks if you're loving friday and
hating sunday
change your life yeah because you should
be loving every day [ __ ] the weekends
being the only time you have fun that
was what it was in school for me i hated
school so friday was great sunday night
i was like miserable i have a whole week
i gotta get up early that's i think
that's that's it yeah
so that's my success was figuring that
out and it had nothing to do with the
fact that i sold my company you know two
or three times and made money or
had celebrities in a restaurant that you
know or a nightclub and i felt cool or i
got laid or any of those things no it
was figuring out that moment of like
none of it really matters
other than enjoying your moment of time
here which is 24 hours a day and if you
do the math
and you start talking to older people
and they start thinking like how many
summers do i have left yeah you don't
really know because you could die
tomorrow but let's just say right now
yeah well well [ __ ] it means you better
enjoy the [ __ ] out of every day
so why would i start later doing that
i'm starting i started that thought at
23.
sometimes i'm by myself and do you
believe i get um i'm eating peanuts or
something
and i get caught in my throat and i'm
bad
and it came out and i bought it but i
was already dozing off so i went out
boom and hit the floor
and i was saying i was in the house by
myself and if that thing was that i
would have died and nobody wanted to
know wasn't that [ __ ] i'm a creepy thing
yeah out of all the things
yeah it's crazy peanut yeah people fall
in the shade they hit their head on the
toilet i mean i was like
i agree with what you just said it's
really you know perspective i was
miserable my last company that the last
two years i was having a great time
built it from ground up and then it
started to get too corporate and i was
like i gotta get out of this
um and my wife's like just go do your
thing like she
we met when we were young i met married
at 24 but we were together at 22.
and she always pushed me i'm like well
i'm going to take a huge pay cut i'm
going to start my own company which i do
here she's like go [ __ ] do that
i think to answer your question my best
experiences are you know both starting
filo and usana and it comes down to the
people around me like it's success it's
about the people around you too
obviously my wife was my success to push
me to where i'm at and i have a happy
family but then all the people that took
risks to come with you and then the
energy like so for me when you talk
about energy or my whole executive team
in the field i work with all these
people for years it took a huge shot to
come to cannabis but when we
had successful moments and we haven't
had our exit like you have or yet we're
succeeding um we saw it went public but
it's about the energy of people that
you're surround yourself with because
like you said you could be you can work
in any company it could be google or any
of these companies you can still be
miserable so it's how you surround
yourself because then you're happy on
sunday you had a great week with your
family monday you're gonna have a great
week with your work family right and so
that's for me the business like the
business success i've had so far in the
past three years is the people the
energy
and the competitiveness to not against
each other like you said i like what you
said just not you don't you don't be
jealous of people it's work and focus on
yourselves and your company and you'll
be successful worry about someone else
you're worried about competition in the
restaurant space i'm worried about
competition in the campus space i don't
worry about that i know that if we call
the right place we'll be successful and
not worry about all the noise so that's
kind of for me it's just that's been my
business yeah
i just think we should just be kind
people when we do tyson ranch kind of
considering and want people
to cheat us with the kindness and
dignity as well yeah hundred percent
got to live you got to have some you
gotta have empathy and you got i mean
colby if anything i'm guessing for you
for any of us is probably the most
challenging time to be a ceo or founder
of a company to really understand how to
talk to your people during those times
that at least you learned the word
furlough yeah i don't even know what
that means people like are you
furloughing i was like further
now it's a normal word but like yeah
there's
furlough is when you fire people
basically that sounds like some prison
words to me for a long time yeah no it's
not that but it's just yeah when you go
to visit something
you know this is uh
this is just
a work
covid for business you know i think was
a um
it was once again another double-edged
sword it was terrible but it provided
opportunity to
um adapt and pivot and
and and come out hopefully if you could
survive
better and more efficient and approach
your future business your next chapter
post covid differently than you did
going into it i think a lot of people
were fat and happy they over they were
making money so they just over hired or
they overpaid and i think employees got
you know lazier but they wanted more to
do less and suddenly it was like slam in
the face to everybody from the top down
like work hard make yourself you know
the people that we kept on you know
obviously as much as we could but you
know the people that you could not lose
you could not do your business without
them well that's that's that says
something and then i think people will
learn from that on both sides the hiring
the people that are hiring and also the
people that are being hired
to become
more valuable
and it's not just about give me my
paycheck it's about like let me add
value and good energy and get along with
and who you want to go to war with
because that was a war we went into the
covid with like you know like battle to
survive it's crazy yeah for
business-wise i'm still baffled that a
peanut almost took you down
i'm going down it came out but it always
got me always i was already in that zone
what a trip mike are you still singing a
lot
singing yeah
well um i never think
personally out in the open but
do you want to pay for some lessons
i'm just kidding
and you're not playing golf right your
son's playing golf right the possibility
i might be as caddy or something you
know i think your son is taking lessons
where i i'm on the board of ugp the golf
urban golf yes he's the stroke of 187
for a 10 year old that's amazing that's
awesome he's gonna hit 200 balls a day
we hit besides working out when he hold
me at 500 balls today that's awesome he
loves this [ __ ] your daughter's playing
tennis
yeah
i can't believe this guy loves this
stuff you know
um
yeah
it's great golf is great
against your own score allow these two
men tell you about the success
and the um
mediocre rise of tyson ranch i'm chad
bradson founder and ceo of filo um
jumped into the cannabis space three
years ago we grew pretty quickly about a
200 person company we work with all the
major msos in essence in the space we
met tyson mike tyson and tyson ranch
through that process and we've gotten to
work with them really closely
and we're pumped to see what tyson ranch
is going to do over the next two years
this guy's a legend and with the team
around all people i'm gonna pump it out
man we're gonna pump this yeah all these
people yeah
yeah there it is
and there you go there it is half the
scene right there
that's what we were waiting for okay
and then we're gonna [ __ ] crush
things with we sana and everything we're
doing we're
we're blessed to be partners with you
thank you and zine kiki a whole group
and everybody and we're excited
kirk thank you all the team you guys
have great people yeah thank you very
much you've been really
amazing turn dan
explain what you're doing with tyson
ranch
the enthusiasm that you do with it yeah
so um daniel carcillo um i'm the ceo and
uh founder of usana we sauna health we
are um you know
partnered with you uh obviously on on a
research partnership with the wbc thank
you so much of course so thank you
you've like chad said you azim kiki
everybody's been amazing to work with um
opened a lot of doors a lot of
possibilities and we're excited about
the future and what we're going to do
to help people with their neurological
health and wellness and
you know hopefully with the anti-aging
thing and who knows where the path is
going to take us but we are developing
you know diagnostics
um we have five clinics now us uh doing
uh ketamine treatment um for you know
various uh psychiatric conditions
it just depends on on the individual how
much would you use for me
ketamine yeah i mean i'm not a doctor
but uh you know we could figure that out
with our with our doctor that we have on
board our cmo we're going through the
fda process um to uh to create the first
pharmaceutical for tbi related anxiety
and depression and just excited about
the development path and and everything
that's um
that's coming for us in the future you
know and being able to help people now
right with education and awareness
that's that's um that's the most
important thing so yeah i really
appreciate you man appreciate you
opening your doors and and uh
introducing us to your family and
getting to know you better part of the
family too amen yeah it's been a great
journey yeah it's been an awesome
journey and then we'll have to meet you
too
and then we're gonna have to go to mj
biz and mark's gonna hook us all up a
catch yeah before our uh big event
yeah if you're gonna have michael's
throat is
we're going to throw our dinner at
mike's college yeah yeah we're in vegas
yeah october 21st
he'll be there yeah he'll come i'll be
yours
he's coming back from his head after
africa okay um
what's those guys named news cameras and
they're checking this [ __ ] out yeah
it'll be great you'll be the man you
already know you'll be the double man
yeah i do my best
anyway i'm mark birnbaum uh founder
co-founder of catch restaurant group
and um we have uh a seafood and sushi
restaurant called what we now call catch
o.g in new york it's our 10-year
anniversary actually this year is our
first one
we also have one here in los angeles and
las vegas and we're building
we have a catch stake which is our
newest one which we opened just before
covet hit about nine months before
it was a great success and we're now
expanding that to catch
steak in l.a on melrose place here and
then one in aspen i'm building now will
open this uh winter actually right
before new year's
and uh we'll see what else is to come
but um
you know generally speaking i just love
having you guys as customers and friends
and
i've been a you know an enormous fan of
yours for as long as i can remember and
pretty much got me into sports
so thanks for all that you've done and
i'm excited to see you as you know
please it's like an honor to be here so
good meeting you
my voice too
and um
let's keep going boys this is just just
the beginning that's what i'm feeling
like i hear you know
he's being very humble he has the best
food in the country
i'm saying he's too he's really he's
very smart very accurate very truthful
man yeah
and i thank everybody for watching
boxing and i like just thanking my
friends than you love for mark and my
man chad and we all love you and we are
out
[Music]
you